[music]
>> Only four of you are confident
and
sure that inshallah
three first 12 sets of verses
90% accuracy
1%
85% accuracy
60%
The rest of you all are less than 60%?
All 12 sets of verses?
English inshallah all.
Arabic
>> Mashallah. Inshallah inshallah. Arabic
300%
and then many verses I know like for
example
I don't know the Arabic
so you know the part that's used for the
hour
but I don't know the entire
thing in Arabic.
>> I disagree with Ashi.
You know you telling that I know the
part which is used for the the other
part is not used for the you mean to say
that? Of course you can use everything
for the hour.
>> I'm telling you this verse specifically.
Referring to this verse.
Now you're reading it.
Yeah.
Understood? Can we use that for the hour
the first part of the verse? Of course.
Of course. Specific.
The first half is actually more
important for the
Do you agree with me? Yeah like
me? Yeah like yeah.
So what I know is
when Zakir bhai when he quotes sometimes
it's that much so that's how I learned
that much not further than that. You
didn't give the example of this verse
earlier you said this verse so I collect
Just to prove my point just to prove it.
Masha Allah.
So nobody wants to give it away.
Brother Azran Chan
Yes sir.
As a daee
You're a daee right? Yes sir.
Alhamdulillah.
So you want to give talks on dawah to
inspire and motivate
the Muslims
to take up the profession to take up the
duty of dawah.
But you are yourself not striving hard
to learn the verses can I know the
reason why?
I hope I get the chance I
I hope I get the chance I uh
I
slowly I'm slowly reading.
Mhm? I'm slowly I'm slowly reading.
How slow? Can you define to me how slow?
How much time would you take to learn
one verse?
Fadi said I should say lines. Okay, one
line.
One line, Arabic and English. How much
time would you take?
One line. I didn't say one word. Yeah.
One line. [clears throat] Mhm. Yeah, if
you
How much time? No, just give me the
time. How much time would you take to
learn one line
with the English translation?
It'll be easier if you put the alphabet
letter. If you did the the the
>> Brother, you just tell me how much time
would you take?
Arabic, one line with the English
translation. Specific question, specific
answer. Yeah, maybe an hour or two.
An hour or two?
Yeah.
Brother Adnan, "Qul huwallahu ahad." Do
you know that? "Qul huwallahu ahad."
>> What is the translation?
Say that Allah is one. How much time did
you take?
That one because I knew before.
>> I'm asking how much time would you take?
How much time? Don't tell me whether you
knew or not. How much time did you take?
Take uh
10 minutes.
10 minutes maybe.
>> Then why are you saying 2 hours? To
learn one line of Arabic with its
English translation, you would take 2
hours?
Yeah.
>> Mhm?
Maybe you it'll be faster if you get the
the
alphabet.
What alphabet? You know how to read the
Quran, right? Arabic. Slower than the
alphabet.
If the alphabet, it'll be faster.
The Quran is
>> Slower than the alphabet? What do you
mean by that? The
Roman Roman Roman uh
>> [laughter]
>> Roman alphabet.
>> Can you read Arabic text? Yes, but it's
crawling compared to the Roman alphabet.
No.
In Arabic or in Roman? By Roman he means
to say the transliteration
into English.
Transliteration.
Wherein if it is "Qul", they write it as
Q U L "Qul".
So normally do you read the
transliteration or direct Arabic text?
From 2 hours. It came down to 10
minutes. Masha Allah.
That's what I was trying to make you all
understand that
the one who is to be blamed for not
performing is you yourself.
Because you have already created
boundaries in your mind. You have come
with a set mindset. Quranic verses in
Arabic, it's impossible.
You have made that mindset.
For one verse,
2 hours.
Subhan Allah.
It barely takes few minutes.
And if a person knows how to read,
it may take him 15 minutes maybe
most.
But a person who does not know maybe two
times more time, three times more time,
but yet he would learn.
So please change your mindset.
Anyone who has come with a mindset to
this Dawah training program thinking
that he would not be able to memorize
the Arabic, he is mistaken it.
So change this mindset.
Do not put restrictions to yourself.
Specially with the book of Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala which Allah has guaranteed
in four different verses which I quoted
earlier, Surat Al-Qamar, chapter 54,
verse number 17, 22, 32, and 40.
In the same sura
where Allah has made the Quran easy to
memorize, it is only you who can change
this.
You who can change this.
Brother Abu Sha'aris
Can you pass him the mic to brother Abu
Sha'aris?
As-salamu alaykum. Wa alaykum as-salam
wa rahmatullahi. Brother Abu Sha'aris,
how much time would you take to learn
one line? Brother, let's uh
put all that aside.
While you were speaking for like 15-20
minutes,
uh
I tried to memorize one verse and I
managed. Masha Allah. Masha Allah.
So, again So, brother
>> Alhamdulillah.
I feel very embarrassed. I think I
didn't put enough efforts.
I was trying to memorize only the
English ones and I spent more than 5
hours alhamdulillah since yesterday
and I got jumbled up.
But, uh
while listening to you when you're so
persistent,
I just said, "Something is wrong with
you. Either you don't understand my
problem or something is wrong with me
that I didn't try." So, while you were
going around with everybody, there's one
ayah here, Al-Ghashiyah 88:21-22, I just
tried.
For the sake of trying. Alhamdulillah,
within like 15-20 minutes, I think I got
it.
>> [laughter]
>> So, inshallah, these 12 verses What's
the time now?
Uh not not before sleep. So, that proves
that you need a man with a stick in his
hand.
Huh? It's better you than the other man,
you know.
If I keep a stick in my hand
and I ask you to learn inshallah,
everyone would be able to learn in 15
minutes, inshallah. Brother, wallahi,
it's better you than than anybody else.
That clearly proves
that inshallah
if you want to strive in the cause of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, it's not at
all difficult.
If you put in the efforts, inshallah,
you would definitely be able to learn
it. All the 12 sets of verses for those
who can read, insha'Allah, it should not
take more than 2 hours.
And for the ones
who are unable to learn it, as I said,
two times more the time, maybe three
times more the time.
English, masha'Allah, everybody can
learn it.
Because everyone, masha'Allah,
knows English.
The Arabic three brothers, out of the 20
participants, 17, masha'Allah, can read.
So, you only three have to put in some
extra effort.
Two times more the effort, three times
more the effort. And insha'Allah, more
the effort you put, the more the help of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala will come to
you.
The more you strive, the more you would
see Allah's help come to you.
And I firmly believe, insha'Allah, that
you three would be among the excellent,
insha'Allah.
If you strive, with the condition if you
strive.
Without being overconfident,
without being under-confident, but being
confident.
And believing in the help of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala, insha'Allah, you
would be able to learn. So, we have
already spent
30 minutes
or more.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allah.
Allah.